remember this it's now clear that
so-called fake news can have real world
consequences Lincoln was just coming off
her loss to Donald Trump we didn't know
it at the time but this speech marked an
important turning point in American
politics the political establishment and
its sympathizers in the Press sought to
convince Americans that Not only was
democracy under attack but so too was
reality itself and what was the enemy's
super weapon
disinformation journalist Jacob Siegel
laid out the origins of this panic in a
guide to understanding The hoax of the
century an essay and tablet The hoax is
the false claim and I would argue the
deliberately false claim that the United
States and indeed all liberal
democracies are under a dire existential
threat from disinformation that was so
dangerous in the way it undermined the
foundations of electoral legitimacy and
liberal democracy itself that it
required a a wartime response and a
wartime mobilization meaning the
suspension of due process of
constitutional rights and protections
and the giving over of the political
system itself to security agencies and
their adjuncts within the administrative
bureaucracy so that they could protect
us from this disinformation threat which
was you know like more dangerous than
terrorism because it was everywhere at
once coming in through our our very
screens and and iPhones Siegel says
there's one big problem with all that
all of this constitutes The hoax because
there was no grave threat from
disinformation let alone a existential
threat that justified the sort of state
of exception that was used to
fundamentally re-engineer the political
system in the United States which is
what took place newspaper headlines
warned Americans that Russian
disinformation had cost Clinton the
election and CIA director turned NBC
News analyst John Brennan theorized that
Trump was being blackmailed by Russia I
think he's afraid of the president of
Russia why um well I think one can
speculate as to why that the Russians
may have something on him personally a
two-year 32 million dollars
investigation turned up no evidence that
Trump colluded with or was compromised
by Russia in terms of the 2016 outcome a
better explanation is that Clinton had
been one of the least popular
presidential candidates in American
history and Russian troll Farms were
responsible for a tiny fraction of the
political content that appeared on
social media during the election so how
did the notion of aggressively policing
Diss and misinformation catch on in the
first place
Siegel says it comes down to a
progressive technocratic mindset that
aims to treat individuals as empty
vessels that need to be filled with the
correct opinions there's a sort of
special Synergy between
progressivism not liberalism but
progressivism and and techno
surveillance States they they do share
certain
important things in common that sort of
can you talk a little bit about them I
mean is what what is that is it that
individuals are are stupid or prone to
being you know galled into the wrong
decision so they know yes yes what else
faith in the expert Class A faith in the
idea that um things uh converge towards
singular correct
um outcomes or decisions that can be
discerned through technical processes
that technocratic attitude is on Full
display in a series of statements from
the public intellectual and podcaster
Sam Harris who defended the idea that
suppressing the hunter Biden laptop
story though true might have been
Justified so my argument is that it was
appropriate for Twitter
and the heads of big Tech and journal
and the heads of journalistic
organizations
to feel that they were in the presence
of something like a a once in a lifetime
moral emergency and we cannot afford to
have four more years with this guy right
and and so
um
so what what should
well-intentioned people do who have a
lot of power in these various ways you
know you're running the New York Times
you're running CNN you're running
Twitter
what should they've conspire to do the
way I would frame it is uh
listen I don't care what's in Hunter
Biden's I made a hunter Biden at that
point Hunter Biden literally could have
had the corpses of children in his
basement I would not have cared Sam
Harris has decided that it doesn't
matter what's on Hunter Biden's laptops
it doesn't matter that Twitter and
Facebook censored and repressed this
what matters is that he recognizes the
grave danger of Donald Trump so here we
have a very important connection which
is the connection between the kind of
underlying let's call it the the sort of
metaphysical layer of the technocratic
mind which he is a supreme
representative of on the one hand and
the oligarchic ruling party certainty
that it is in the best position to
decide whose votes should count whose
votes shouldn't count what information
can be seen what information can't be
seen But the good news is that this
total dominance the information sphere
is unlikely to be realized technology
tends to be a double-edged sword
providing the means to control and
simultaneously the means to evade
control current Technologies are in the
process of giving us a level of privacy
we have never had before
essentially there are now well-known
Ways available in free software of
encrypting messages so that only the
intended recipient can read them as
mathematician Eric Hughes wrote in his
1993 cypherpunk's Manifesto which would
later become a foundational document in
the cryptocurrency and decentralization
movement information does not just want
to be free it longs to be free
his belief that cryptography could lead
to more freedom has been borne out with
the rise of stateless money like Bitcoin
private encrypted messaging platforms
like signal and emerging decentralized
social media projects like Nostra and
Bluesky and it only takes a relatively
small but devoted contingent of users to
keep these potential Escape hatches
propped open for when they're needed
most it's a danger that must be
addressed and addressed quickly
Americans don't need Hillary Clinton or
John Brennan to filter information for
them to keep liberal democracy safe what
we need to keep liberal democracy safe
is unfettered access to real information
about how our government operates and
the freedom to talk about that
information amongst ourselves without
State interference so we could say
broadly speaking that the old rule in
America
was one of self-government broadly
speaking or or of a liberal democracy
that favored a pluralistic Outlook in
which the individual was the proper
subject of State protections counter
disinformation and information
regulation as a a the sort of
foundational philosophical basis of
government just replaces that wholesale
because it declares that the function of
the government is not to protect the
rights of the individual the function of
the government is to protect the
individual and the clients of the
government from external threats in
reality to protect uh protect their own
institutional position and and try and
stay in power
um forever
hey thanks for watching if you'd like to
see our full conversation with Jacob
Siegel about what he's termed to the
counter disinformation complex click
here for a clip from that conversation
click here